Across the nation, proof that education
reforms are working has come from record
graduation rates. But in DC, the
unbelievable progress is just that. After
posting a record 73% grad rate last year,
an audit found one in three DC grads
received diplomas in violation of policy.
Excessive absences were one problem:
nearly a third of graduates missed 50
days in their final year. Another was
credit recovery, which offered easy
makeup classes to students who never
took the original courses. All told, if DC
had followed policy, its grad rate would
have fallen below 50%. So is DC an
outlier or the canary in the coal mine?
Well, under similar pressure for results,
grad rate issues surfaced in Maryland,
Chicago, LA, New York, and elsewhere. Look, everyone wants more students to graduate.
These shortcuts aren't the answer. They
make it hard for us to tell which
districts are actually pushing more
students to earn diplomas. DC is a lesson
that we can't improve the lives of
students or school systems unless school
leaders push our students to new heights,
rather than just pretending to.
How do you think school districts can make real
progress on graduation rates? Let us know
in your comments. Also, let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI.